Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
worldwide press conference we have a
slate of stars and filmmakers with us
let's introduce them first is producer
Deborah Snyder second is star Holly
Hunter third star Jesse Eisenberg Gaul
Godot star Ben Affleck director Zack
Snyder henry cavill amy adams
Larenz Fishburne and producer choice row
thank you welcome them all I have a
microphone great greetings Aria Charles
Zack we're gonna start up here and then
we're gonna open it up to the quit to
the press you are known as a director
who is unafraid of big projects I
remember they said Watchmen was a film
that couldn't be made was this at all
intimidating what drew you into this
weirdly um I think that if we had not
evolved the project the way we did it
would have been a little bit more
intimidating if for instance someone
just come up to me and said hey do you
want to a movie where Batman fights
Superman I would like ego okay he's back
a little bit but because it kind of you
know it kind of evolved over time by the
time we were shooting I think was the
first time I realized 100% like I think
it's a camera test when I was actually
looking at Batman and Superman and their
costumes and I realize like we're gonna
that's going to happen huh so um yeah
but but amazing and fun and an honor to
you know deal with these icons so it's
it's great start with questions be
handsome
oh good morning uh sorry lose my voice
here Bruce Kirkland Toronto Sun Sun
media in Canada so this is a question
leading out of
where's AK was just touching upon for
both Henry and ban in regards to having
these iconic superheroes and you've been
down this path in obviously in Man of
Steel Henry and Bennett's a new for you
but bringing them into the same world
and having an emotional base as well as
all of the action in the film I'm
curious what went into working out your
own identities and then pitting them
against each other
hmm yeah I'll start an easy one to start
what went into it again as I always say
it's going to the source material
there's an awful lot of psychology in
Superman because it's the one way you
can find to crack the shell and when it
comes to playing the character
especially in this movie where we still
see the growth of Superman before seeing
the finished product of what we know and
love from the character in the comic
books it's it was just delving into the
psychology and the weaknesses they're in
and playing with the relationship of
between him and Lois and him and Martha
and then of course the conflict he has
when facing the likes of Batman yeah for
me there was really enough material in
the screenplay that that Chris Terrio
wrote and with Zach's direction there
was a you know plenty for me to grab on
to and to help you know use my
imagination to try to build this
character as you were Scott was just
saying it's certainly daunting because
of the people who have like played this
character before and the great
filmmakers you know most recently
obviously Christian and Chris did three
brilliant movies and all the guys who
went before them there's that element of
sort of healthy respect you have for the
project and for the characters and their
history and you know raises the bar
certainly and I felt that I was in
really good hands with with the script
and with Zach and so that that was where
I focused my attention
hi guys tea left over here I'm David
from Israel I wonder if you can comment
by working with our national pride and
joy sitting to your left
mr. athletic mr. Rick Campbell I was a
tremendous treat she's the best ha ha ha
no really far so good
back out that's such a great amazing job
and made all the scenes that I was in
with her better made me better and she's
she's my favorite part of the movie when
she shows up and I don't give anything
away but uh she helps me out this many
today and uh she's a terrific actress
and I think one of them is going to be
very good and III just a lot of fun I'm
excited to keep working with him it's
tough to sound genuine by just repeating
that but it's true god no is it cool
yeah ditto
gal cuts a fine figures one woman she
brings something particular something
statuesque something something
otherworldly to the character and it's
remarkable to see you're welcome
I am Jeffrey Taylor with movies calm and
Fandango I've got a question that
actually applies to several of you the
question is this there I'm a fan a big
fan and I deal with a lot of fans who
can be sometimes irrational and times
when somebody gets cast wait what what
sometimes events can be a little bit of
rationale when a casting announcement is
made and it's not what they expected and
wondering how you might deal with that
when you do hear something like that
from fans either on social media or or
any other place and I guess this would
would apply to um Jessie gal been in in
some ways Amy and in some ways Lauren's
from from from what I read everything
very much yeah cast Henry first so then
they were like and then after that
they're like what does he do he's lost
his mind
yes it's it's certainly strange and and
and unnerving to be criticized for a
part you haven't yet been able to screw
up but I you know I think I think I
probably also would have been surprised
had ice you know read that I was playing
Lex Luthor without having had access to
this wonderful script and this
incredible character written by Chris
Terrio who created a character that I
thought was suitable for me you know if
you look at just the Canon
the mythology of and the history of
Superman I might not be the first person
to come to mind but if you read the
script and understood how the character
was contextualized in this kind of like
modern era and the way he was written I
knew that I could do it well and I knew
that you know or at least I hoped that
after people had seen the movie they
would understand that I was more
appropriate than they had originally
feared I wish I had heard you say that
two days ago I could have just xeroxed
it for all my very well said yeah I
agree with them as well um also I you
know you can't please them all and for
me being an actress my responsibility is
not to pay too much attention to all the
noise around me but to pay attention to
the script to the director that I'm Zak
um and and be and protect the character
and try to tell her story the best I can
and I can only do my best I am Jill for
the West Australian I have a hello
oh how are you going that's a long story
I was blast one good eye you work out
what colors no um um it all began when
Warner Brothers one wanted to addition
me to something they would not say what
ah so of course I was intrigued and I
did the audition and Zach was there and
it was great and two weeks later they
asked me to do a camera test with Ben I
said great what am I being what what's
the role what's fun they said well my
agent told me honestly they would not
say award but expect a phone call from
Zach Zach called me the same night and
he was saying well I'm not sure if you
have it in Israel but did you ever hear
about Wonder Woman my I literally I
think I went dad for like few good
seconds came back to life and then I
tried to pull off my best voice
saying Wonder Woman yeah yeah Wonder
Woman and then I did the camera test
with Ben which was great and and then is
fantastic and seven weeks later it was a
torture I literally went through seven
stages of grief the first two weeks I
felt good about that I had a good
feeling and then from then on I started
to be angry and to be like I it was bad
but finally seven weeks later they
called to say that I got the part and
that's that that was it we are thank you
I knew right away so I'm sorry about
that dad something you know hi i'm
jabari p this is for a Zack Snyder and
and Deborah how uh how critical is this
movie er can you just talk about the
importance of this movie to launching
this this sort of expanded universe and
expanded franchise of DC movies again I
think the thing that's interesting about
the process with this movie and sort of
the way it's evolved is that you know
the idea of having Batman fight Superman
is ridiculous it's ridiculous
so that's why we've made it is not only
ridiculous but also once we had
committed to that ridiculous idea we
were it was then only that we were like
okay so that implies that a universe
exists where Batman and Superman exist
together which was that weird I know it
seems like obvious ins weird in comic
book in the comic book world but had not
existed really in them in the movies so
though it seems like an obvious notion
if you're you know just sort of casually
like oh well Batman and Superman of
course they they they're both comic-book
heroes so yeah they like down the street
from each other right like they bump
into each other all the time that's
maybe whether met but they uh but so
once that sort of idea had taken root
and
existed as reality it was then only that
we were like well I was really obsessed
with I am and have been obsessed with
the Trinity and really wanted to see the
Trinity that being Batman Superman
Wonder Woman in a single moment and that
was a thing that I was really interested
in in trying to get into this movie not
that I didn't have enough to deal with
already but I thought that would be a
cool thing to see and those
conversations are really what led to
this dawn of Justice kind of subheading
for the film and that we could now begin
to talk about or have conversations
about the fact that the Justice League
and/or the DC Universe now could evolve
from this and we you know I feel like
frankly we adjust you know it's a
difficult it's a difficult notion
especially at a studio like this that's
really filmmaker driven and sort of
project to project you know the very
difficult notion to say okay well you're
making a movie but it's actually
connected to that guys movie and
connected to that guys movie and they're
all going to be it's all going to be a
great big fun sandbox we're all going to
play nice in it which is a great thing
but it's a difficult thing to just make
a pier and I think that's the great
that's what the luck and sort of
serendipitous nature of this movie
that's allowed the worlds now to kind of
coalesce and I don't think it was a it
became a plan and it's becoming a thing
but it was only in those kind of in its
infancy that we realized yeah oh my gosh
this can this can be a thing and at the
same time I think we wanted to set up
and introduce these characters but we
also had a really rich story to tell so
it was a careful balance about telling
the story the Batman and Superman story
and giving a little hint and a tease to
the story of Justice League that's yet
to come question on the lip - question
for Charles I'm right in here can you
talk a little about being the overseer
of the bringing the DC Universe to the
screen how hands-on you have to be does
it make you the water
this version of Kevin Feige for example
well I think it's you know it's a team
of us the the team is obviously Debbie
Zack myself Geoff Johns is part of it it
the interesting and fun it's a very
interesting challenge and but it's also
a lot of fun because even when we were
making films that might have sequel
possibilities we never really in the
past even like what the Dark Knight
never really thought about what exactly
the next movie going to be the in fact
you know when we went from Batman Begins
The Dark Knight we didn't even because
we ended the Batman Begins with the
Joker we thought okay we'll probably
should do the Joker on the next one but
we never really had a story right here
here we're constantly thinking in the
future not only how to make each
individual film stand on its own be
compelling be fun be thought-provoking
have great characters but we're also
thinking way down the road about how
these things are going to interconnect
and makes sense and also leave room for
other great filmmakers to be involved
and to make sure that while we want to
get to a certain place we don't stay too
rigid and too fixed on exactly the
methodology of how we get there we have
to leave room for the creative process
to allow it to evolve and it's just
really exciting and challenging every
single day
oh he's hands-on we're shooting one
woman out his hand zone definitely I
think wherever you are in the world
because we're making a number of these
in different phases we always have to be
thank God all I can say for high
technology because you really have to be
you have to stay connected so if if if
Debbie's in Los Angeles and I'm in
London or Zach's commuting back and
forth or for making a film in Toronto
you just have to stay in touch with it
through every
form of of medium that you can and it
every day is long because somewhere you
know somewhere on some continent there's
a portion of one of the movies that
you're working on got rather chef Nick
from IDEO Donald Israel let me speak I'm
assuming we exist in the fictitious
reality be set up in Batman V Superman
when you ask me what Clark came I'd ask
myself and or Ben and I believe Clark
would ask something on the lines of what
do you think the value of Batman is and
watching the value of the Superman is I
that's a good question Clark experience
I didn't even think I had to once my
excellent question
in the fictitious reality it is
explained very clearly in the movie and
I agree with it that's from Israeli
there's a hot girl in super super girl
ah you became you made history you
became the first Wonder Woman in the
movies ah do you often think for
yourself like me gal gadot from small or
shine from Israel made it big and how
was your last week you crazy week um
it's a huge honor to be the one who got
this amazing opportunity to tell such an
important story and I'm sorry this last
week I've been taking many interviews
and I'm starting to lose my voice um hmm
sorry so it's been a great honor to be
the one who's gonna tell this amazing
story I feel very very grateful no never
in my life I never imagined I never
planned on being an actress I never
planned on being Wonder Woman everything
happened and I'm
grateful and happy and I'm and I'm in
love with with what I do um um what was
the next question the other one last my
last week or okay
you want me to tell about all shine
logic iron is a very small city close to
Tel Aviv ah the last week was very very
intensive I was very very excited about
it
um I had many talk shows I reunite with
the people that I love that I'm work
I've been working on this magnificent
movie I hope you all enjoyed it by the
way you better worked hard um and and
it's great and I'm happy to be here and
it's happening and I'm kind of still in
denial I'm so busy working that I have
absolutely no time to sit down and relax
and enjoy the ride I'm enjoying
everything but I think that it'll take
me some time until I really understand
what's going on oh you've been quiet
over there what's it like to have a
character written into the DC Universe
that character was specifically written
for you oh well I guess that's kind of
liberating um and you know in in
comparison with everybody else on that
panel um but it was it was lovely to
kind of have a character who was in the
midst of this mayhem of the story and
kind of bring some sense and sensibility
to the to the proceedings
and be dealing with a character is as
combustible as Lex and especially as as
Jesse's Lex is as as volatile and
complicated and emotional as he is it
was really a fun ride to take with him
and kind of negotiate the waters of
staying incredibly open and curious to
what his point of view was and then as
knowledge accumulates to arrive at a
decision that that I felt was um
rational and reasonable Lawrence and
Diane you are a veteran of the superhero
genre was this a different experience
what's it like to enter a world that big
where you're combining that many heroes
well you just don't think the stakes can
get higher and then suddenly find out
they can I mean it's it's definitely
thrilling to witness the film and the
final product and see my read in the
tapestry and how it reverberates
throughout the story also selfishly it
was very lovely too on both films be the
commencement of this huge production you
know Martha provides a gentle beginning
I would think comparative to where we're
headed so it's nice to break in the crew
and have the first day of school all
together
Lawrence what's it like to be an editor
do you get to take on the press take us
down oh I don't know anything about that
I just learned my lines and said um I
just you know as I'm really more of a
fan you know I'm a I'm a comic book
reader and a collector and have been
since I was a kid and really for me this
movie is it's a movie I've been waiting
to see for 35 years I can't even believe
I'm in the movie you know I believe we
have a question hi my name is Jamie
broad knacks my outlet is black girl
nerds my readers are very excited that
I'm here because I have a website that's
about empowering women and women of
color so yes this question is for gal
they're like and I feel wonderful then
um I wanted to ask you Gao first of all
did you watch any of the Lynda Carter
series Wonder Woman growing up when you
were researching this role and also what
advice do you have for women out there
who are actresses that are interested in
doing films that are about comic book
super heroines interesting um the first
question was I'm sorry I'm so jet-lagged
no I was too young to watch with Lynda
Carter TV show I was -5 but after they
cast me for this role I did watch a
couple of episodes I think that Lynda
Carter was a magnificent Wonder Woman
and it's certainly big shoes to to fit
into but when they cast me for this
movie Zak and everyone had a very clear
vision on who wonder woman should be and
and and and what's her story and how
they want to tell it and all I had to do
is really give my own notes and inputs
and just embody everything and and be
her and um I truly think you know I I
have a four year old daughter and she
adores princesses at the same time she
would tell me the princess she's so weak
she falls asleep the prince will come
and save her and kiss her and he's the
hero so I'm so happy that I'm so happy
to be the one who's who's gonna tell the
Wonder Woman story it's such a very it's
such an important story to be told to
tell and and and I'm grateful for it but
I also think that it's so important for
girls and boys to have a female strong
superhero to look up to and the more the
merrier and and there's plenty of room
to many more women to come and I'm very
very happy to be to be a part of that
Allah I love the interested girls and
boys I love that yeah believe we have a
question the first round hi I'm a goalie
from France it's a question for Zak um
it's kind of a big thing in a movie when
Clark and Bruce realize they have their
mother share the same name do you think
this is something that's gonna be
appealing to the fans ah in the set well
it's I mean it's from the comic books
right so but it's very important
yeah I wasn't wanting her I feel like
you know when we when we were talking
about that whole aspect of the movie and
just what is the thing that humanizes
Superman for for Batman it seemed really
interesting to us to kind of think about
it in those terms you know in that you
know he's basically now looking at
someone with a mother you know and
that's different you know it he becomes
different in that moment you know and to
Batman
you know the idea that this what he
would consider an alien what he would
consider sort of this otherworldly
creature that could care less about
humanity and that he could bring himself
to a certain emotional place with that
would be normally difficult for Batman
even to get to that he had got and
whipped himself in into a enough of a
fervor that he could he had achieved a
thing that maybe was even particularly
difficult for him but then to sort of
now see that guy you know look in a
mirror that was that was the idea and
fans I don't know well they'll feel
about it I'll tell you how fans will
feel about it I forgot that they had the
same that their mothers had the same
name but it's my favorite moment in the
movie as a fan when Batman meets Martha
Kent
there you go can I also had one little
tidbit of joy did I get this wrong but
isn't wasn't my scene the first time we
got to experience been in his regalia
that was it was that was the very first
it was very very moment I was fit and it
although I discovered Diane in an
earlier movie where Superman's mom and I
had a different kind of relation thank
you
no offense Henry stop reminding me Gary
very complex fabric hello we're from
Japan and the first we like to ask you
know Oh persons act which is AK um why
did you cast towel you know in this film
I'm a Japanese AK actress oh yeah hello
No and also you know for uh Annie and
Henley and Oh Jesse how was it working
with a towel can you the reason I
castile was because first we were
looking for we had this character in the
script and really I honestly I had seen
Wolverine and thought that she was
amazing in the movie and was like who is
that uh and we she came in and I met
with her and she did an audition that
was amazing and I just was like we we
need to we need to get this woman in the
movie if it's possible and I think since
then it's been she was an amazing honor
and joy to work with on set and just
cool and yeah she's great yeah I thought
she was great and fun and very good
Martin great actress we had a good time
I really didn't get much of a chance to
interact we had a one scene which we
were in the same room for because when
we shot that scene I had no interaction
with her in the
for the Lex Luthor party charity gig
better in Congress I I saw her across
the room and she looked marvelous
oh yeah I loved working with her I think
we probably make a maybe possibly
unintentionally comedic pair um she
plays my assistant although from like an
aesthetic perspective we should probably
switch places and uh and she has a
really unusual and great sense of humor
which you wouldn't expect because you
didn't you wouldn't think that she would
need to Amy are you beginning to feel
like a Superman veteran does this get
easier do you get used to it as a
certain language you need to adopt when
you're playing a superhero character or
the love interest of a superhero
character um I mean no I mean I you
never really get used to it the scale of
it's always really impressive and every
time I walk on set I'm completely blown
away and um what has been so nice is
getting to know everybody over the
course of years and getting to bring
these relationships we've all you know
AM established over the course of
working together and then doing stuff
like this and getting to use that in the
film and kind of we grow as the
characters grow and so it's been a real
joy to just get to come back all these
lovely folks again and all of the new
ones that I just am absolutely in love
with so yeah she just starts to dial up
her moxie I guess I have to dial down
yeah better we've got a question here hi
folks
ed simcha Statehouse media in Boston I'm
a DC Comics fan from the 1950s and when
I first heard the title of this movie I
said come on Superman could beat the tar
out of Batman correct correct
now NV and Ben could you give me your
immediate reactions when you first heard
the title of this did you think it was
ridiculous and how did you come around
to accepting it and also for Zach was
this movie ever going to be called
Superman V Batman who wants a star you
want me to go first it's funny because
like honestly Batman V Superman for me
from a philosophical like you know and
it's the only way I can think about
things
because I'm so philosophical his that
you know we wine I wanted with a man
like the human in the God human
relationship first and you know for me
these guys I don't know if they heard
the title before they heard the concept
so I hope they did it'd be cool if they
just sent him a letter just said that
honor you open it just like that members
who remain like okay what is it a prank
it uh I haven't had a lot of questions
you know it's fun one of my favorite
questions is when someone just says
Batman versus Superman how is this
possible right like this is like well we
made a two hour and plus movie that sort
of explains Batman this is it right
though and by the way I think that
you're right the the notion is crazy but
at the same time it is a well you know
is a well the road is well established
that leads to Batman vs Superman and and
and they're there then being pitted
against each other in the comic books is
not a it's not a thing we made up you
know it's it's a con it's a it's a
Detroit returns was something that was
obviously you know had that set that
precedent before the Frank Miller books
so having seen that I was already tuned
into what it could be and hoping that
that was the sort of angle that that
deck was taking and he had the little
sculpture up from that in his office and
I thought like you know this guy's
definitely on the right track I didn't
think it was crazy because I had read
when I was a kid The Dark Knight Returns
where Frank Miller you know did this
comic where Superman fought in fact
fought Batman and it was really original
and interesting and turn the genre on
its head and it was a morally gray sort
of story and changed the way I saw comic
books so I had been familiar with that
idea you know for a long time and when I
heard that this was the idea of this
movie I thought that's brilliant because
it's one of the great ideas and comics
that hasn't been mined yet for
for films I agree with battlenet one I
knew the comic book especially the Frank
Miller one and also the relationship in
the comic books between Batman and
Superman and the idea was nothing but
exciting because we're opening up the
cinematic universe for the Hall of DC I
believe we have a question in front row
uh Steve from Collider there's a
question actually for everyone I'm
curious if you guys have a day or two or
a sequence from the film that you'll
always remember you know that when you
think back on the making of the film I
think I shared mine as far as the reveal
of Batman and been in the role and how
fabulous he is no that's the new
information I was a little it was a very
unnerving days to the first day wearing
the suit and being on camera you think
well here it is I'm really doing this
and it was very nice to have Diane there
a friendly face and a great actress and
kind of looked at me like you know yeah
it's gonna be okay uh it was so that was
I appreciated that day and if I haven't
told you before it for me it was it's
tough to say while shooting because I
was in a green room at the time but
certainly I feel like I felt it after
having watched the movie but the third
act for me in particular resonated and
it was probably while watch the movie
where I felt the most and got to step
outside of the the actor and was part of
the audience I'm gonna go with the
bathtub scene oh yeah that's it just
kidding trying to lighten up just trying
to lighten it up oh no that was actually
horrible just trying to protect my
modesty and on a flattering garment as
well like the demigods stood above me
with his low self-esteem for two weeks
after that bad
you look fine it's true I really was
like I'm hideous um please anyway she's
not uh and it wasn't it was actually
there's a lot of there's a lot of great
I had so much fun on this film and I
love working with Henry so much and um
really getting to come back to that
relationship in a richer way was really
awesome but there's a moment in the
third act with Diane actually that
became one of my favorite moments it's
just a quiet moment between two women
and just like as an actress I I like
quiet moments over here Sandra Vaughn is
syndicated this right back here this
movie with Batman and Superman have dual
roles regular people superheroes and
it's a it's a debate between power
versus will do you think that your
characters are more willful than
powerful and when you have to lose
yourself into these huge characters what
helps you get there faster your little
boy hero complex or your adult male hero
complex ha ha your sofa for that I have
too many complexes to sort through any
of them will do really event uh you know
it's definitely um I think you're on to
something when you talk about like the
will versus strength of Batman I think
one of the reasons why this character
has resonated since you know the FDR
administration with audiences regardless
of the way the country's changed in pop
culture has changed it's because you
have a guy who on the one hand is
powerful and exciting and can do things
that we all wish we could do which is
also still a human being you know and
struggling with his own vulnerabilities
and fragilities and and and struggling
with his own will and he is a kind of
for accomplishes things by force of will
I think Batman and that was a that was
fun and exciting to to play and yeah
it's definitely but and I think I tapped
eating to equal measured my you know
adult geekness and and kid excitement
for this movie there was there's you can
just see from this like I mean in this
room there's so much every day there was
something new to kind of geek out about
and be excited by and be like I can't
I get to be in this movie you know it
was exciting every day we've got time
for a couple more questions well okay
Ben Steven Schaffer here Boston Herald
when you were growing up as a boy in
Boston did you think about Batman very
much and you gave a great interview with
the New York Times and talked about the
duality of the character and can you
talk about how you see him in this in
this movie and Henry similarly Superman
seems to go through a big change here if
you could talk about that there's a
storm on our street called millionaire
picnic which is still open I think which
is where I bought the Frank Miller book
when I was I don't know what I wasn't -5
I was I had a plus to my age I did the
calculation it was minus ten okay rub it
in thanks yeah I was old enough to be
wandering around the city by myself so
that separates us the at that stores
still there that's where I bought my
first those first comics and that as I
said was the first comic that I that
really took my appreciation of this
genre to another level it was right when
people were kind of doing those
innovating in that way when Watchmen
came out around the same time and you
know really kind of newer more adult
sophisticated complicated ways of
looking at this world started to be
developed within the comic genre it took
the it took the movie business 20 years
to catch up to start making to be
willing to you know really mine these
stories in this genre for complicated
and interesting and resonance rich
stories but but it has now obviously and
yes that's where I was that but I can't
remember what else that's why I bought
them Oh the duality the part yeah I mean
it Bruce Wayne it's like Zack often said
that he thought Bruce Wayne was kind of
a mask or a character that he put on you
know as much as Batman was and he liked
the idea that there was this ritual sort
of you know just putting on the suit and
getting ready and either way he looked
and the whole thing was like a way of
putting on a mask to the world of
presenting this alter ego Bruce Wayne
person to the world and I thought that
was interesting and I liked the idea
that both Bruce Wayne and Batman were
really sort of unhealthy people you know
who
engaging an unhealthy behavior at night
as a result of like you know
psychological scars they board from
childhood and and I thought that was a
that that duality was something that was
really interesting to explore me this
felt very much like the development of
Superman of the character who we know
and love in the comic books we're still
not there yet we are looking at the guy
growing up he's become this Superman um
after discovering he was kal-el in the
first movie and now he's facing off
against his second guy and it's a tough
outing for him because it's against a
psychological enemy as opposed to a
physical enemy like Zod was and we see
him make mistakes and we see him grow
those mistakes and learn from them we
have time for one more question it's
going to come from the back Chris
Richburg EU our web mr. Schneider this
is actually a two-part question mr.
Schneider mrs. Schneider this movie
deals with a lot of heavy themes
you definitely have consequences the
consequences of consequences God vs Man
and the overall theme family in light of
this in terms of balance how much of a
challenge was it to balance all of those
elements in addition to the speak and in
addition to the action that's automatic
in the film yeah it is a bit it is a
balance but I think that you know when
you when you sort of look at the tone of
the movie to me I've always been
interested tone to me is the is the
number one aspect of a film that I
really am interested in and this movie
is you know it is at the same time a
deconstruction as it is a construction
it's a it is self reflexive in some
subtle ways in that you know when you
have icons of this magnitude and
comic-book characters of this magnitude
and sort of mythology of this magnet
is you have to there's a little bit of
letting off the hook you know we never
we take it heart attack serious but at
the same time there's a self-awareness
to the movie that I think you you have
to have in order for the movie to
resonate on a second on any kind of
second level beyond just oh look these
two superheroes are fighting and you
know that's cool
I think that I think that the movie and
Chris Terrio has written an amazingly
intelligent script about what it means
what power is what justice is you know
what our relationship to these mythic
characters are is it a relationship
between God and man all these questions
you know and I think that you know to me
that that's the balance you know more
than the balance between action and
drama and and that that's natural to the
story you you know you run into conflict
but to me it it really this movie is fun
because I got to have fun with these
characters to tell maybe a slightly
bigger story than just Batman vs
Superman though I am satisfied Mike the
dork in me is completely satisfied by
that I do think that there's the film is
richer and and it's it's it was funded
to work on an idea that maybe as bigger
even than just Batman vs Superman and I
think to put these characters in a real
world I think that they're easier to
relate to we can never imagine what it's
like to have superpowers
you know I but if we see them going
through struggles if we see them kind of
messing up and picking themself up and I
think that's really relatable and I
think we like to you know see stories
that mirror ourselves
you